to help extend the life of the filters you use with your CPAP machine
if you place an air purifier right below it
it's gonna clean the air that's getting fed straight into your CPAP machine
so it's not like I'm trying to purify all the air in the whole entire room
I'm just trying to make sure that where the CPAP is placed
it's kind of like getting fed the cleanest air so that it's easier on the CPAP
and other people on the internet have talked about this
it really is helpful I got this one from the TikTok shop
I really really like it
it's really helpful it has a child lock
so little fingers are not gonna come and accidentally turn it off
and it has a timer so just right before you turn the C pop machine on
you hit the timer button
to make sure that it's only gonna run for the eight hours
it's really quiet
and it really does help the C pop machine at be as effective as it can be
because it's not working hard to clean the air
and the filter in here is only one little layer of Protection
so this really does add another layer of Protection for breathing all night long
like this is the air that's getting shoved down your airway all night long
so I like to make sure it's as clean as possible
cause it's for my daughter
and she's you know